now with two men being questioned under
caution by officers investigating cash
for honors allegations linked to King's
child's charity the prince's Foundation
it's not looking great for the Monarch
in his first few weeks on the job
joining me now to discussed this is talk
to the legend Kevin O'Sullivan the Queen
Elizabeth's form press actually good
friend of mine Dickie arbutter and Daily
Mirror associate editor Kevin McGuire
let's start with you Dicky if we can I
thought you would you would say so he's
got a temper
the queen had a temper Charles has got a
temper William's got it they've all got
it but did any of them ever take money
in a plastic bag from Saudi Arabia
become on the money that that you know
you know I'm a royalist okay isn't that
a good look for a no it's for a monarch
to accept in in and you know that story
is relevant yeah but according to the
charity Commissioners he did nothing
wrong they're all collecting money all
the charges are collecting money
rattling Tins in the street they're
collecting tens of thousands it's cash
okay excuse me I'm sorry he got a bag of
money you didn't do anything wrong you
know these two people they've questioned
Dickie would one of them be forced it do
we think the the the probably the former
right-hand man is is faucet I mean we
don't know if that's true that's an
alleged comment of course but here's the
thing that I find quite interesting
Foster and he were inseparable is is
force it gonna keep quiet out of loyalty
or is he going to spill his guts do you
think because he's been thrown out
royally well he has been thrown out he
was forced to resign because he was
involved in the in the cash for honors
Scandal I mean how he how he got there
in the first place because he's not in a
position to offer uh honors only uh the
government can issue on us in certain
quarters on the other hand the queen is
used to issue honors which the king can
now do but it has to be on the
recommendation of The Sovereign do you
think
um that uh Kevin that Charles's judgment
has been called into into doubt because
of Fawcett because of you know money in
bags or do you think this is just the
people who are anti the monarchy the
Republican arm of the United Kingdom
will do anything to get rid of Matt bear
in mind just how amazingly popular
monarchy is after the last couple of
weeks well the queen was we'll see
whether part of the monarchy died with
her and if he is as popular but he was
shaking the charity tin for the rich
because he was living in in some of the
properties that were being done up with
this cash the money the bag was the
Qatari it could sell it the Saudi is
alleged to have been offered help to get
an honor and citizenship and other
favors and had a forest named after him
at the castle of May in gratitude by
Prince Charles
this is not good and it's why I think
the whole hereditary principle and the
succession being immediate this couldn't
be investigated and scrutinized before
he got the job anybody else go for a job
in public life this was hanging over you
these allegations are made you would be
put on hold you will not be confirmed in
your post until it was cleared up and
there he is he's sitting tight now he's
got the top job and the police are
investigating his business dealings they
did say at the time that he personally
had done nothing wrong Kev Mark II is
this is I mean you're a royalist like me
it is it bad judgment is it the
Republican stirring up a horn it's Nest
how do you see it I think that Prince
Charles as he was then showed appalling
judgment a serial number of times these
sacks full of cash as Dicky quite
rightly says not criminal but a terrible
terrible look the cash for honors it
should never have been involved in that
uh he's got himself into some serious
scrapes and the police May well have to
interview the monarch of this land and
that is how does that work that is bad
yeah however however I wish him well uh
I hope he can control his temper uh and
he needs to I don't like his ideas about
a smaller monarchy I don't like his
ideas about Amiga little coronation we
want Majesty from the royal family we
want the kind of spectacle we saw at the
funeral we want that for the coronation
so I'm not sure he has the right ideas
but but I wish him well but one of his
staff was involved with cash for honors
he personally wasn't involved force it
if it was him was not in a position to
offer honors but then you have dick here
you know I agree with you but then but
then I bring you back to my favorite
subject Boris Johnson had to go but it
was all the people in Downing Street why
did he have to go then does the main man
not have to take responsibility I guess
is the question the main man only takes
responsibility if he knows that that is
right his person is doing look I worked
for him for five years I didn't tell him
everything I was doing I was told to get
on with the job and I got on with a job
if I needed to know something then I
would phone him but cash for honors
that was a rogue employee going off on
his own allegedly enforcer is right hand
man bad judgment to have him as his
right hand man but interestingly Michael
Fawcett Dickey has had to resign three
exactly well there's the argument if if
Charles and apparently I don't know
you'd know more than me apparently it
was Camilla who said you are going to
ruin your your coronation and everything
that's going to happen unless you get
rid of this bloke because this is the
third time that that they're in them and
we're both stories that isn't great
judge the first two times he was fired
uh was he he was fired within the
household he was doing how did he get
back then he got back because he was out
of the household he was running the
charity The Man Who Knew Too Much yeah
yeah
that's bad judgment for Prince Charles
to have this guy back in the foreign
who pays 12 million pounds to keep a sex
case out of court you've got Harry
making all sorts of uh accusations with
his wife that they're they're racist and
pretty deplorable and now you've got
Charles don't get me started
now you've got Charles I thought who
through his foundation as a police
investigation I must say when I read
this and Dicky knows this the old man
worked for the royal family 41 years I'm
a royalist the the last thing the old
man ever said to me was he didn't say
that he said I fear that the monarchy
will never be the same after the Queen
the queen transcended I said this the
other day she transcended I think almost
every part of this country religion
color Creed background social class
because she was this stoic unbelie you
know you said Dickie very honestly she
had a temper I never saw her in 70 well
I wasn't being alive I've never seen her
on day three of course it's a stupid pen
she was this amazing woman she admitted
did she not she made one mistake of the
Abba fan thing in in Wales but but
actually
the monarchy has changed hasn't it we
know more than we ever did before don't
we well yes I mean this is Charles's uh
predicament I mean he's had to live his
whole life in the spotlight yeah uh the
royal family have had it to adapt to the
media and funnily enough I think the
queen was much better at adapting to
this New Media control world than Prince
Charles and King Charles now there is
this sort of aspect to King Charles that
he's he's like a figure from the past
you know a very a Regal character who
snaps at his staff and gets annoyed with
pens you know get that pen sorted out
for me uh something there's something
anachronistic about him and he's got to
raise his game in that respect but as I
keep saying I wish him well and I do
think he's a decent man all of the
problems he's got in do with these sacks
of cash he was just trying to raise
money for charity uh but bad well he was
good
what do you think I was doing taking it
for himself he wasn't taking it for
himself
no yes he did
yeah that's why that's why he's got a
forest the Saudi guy's got a forest
named yes you're making allegations that
he is buildings that he lived in his
building it was it's if you're really
Posh and you've got a load of money
you can have foundations and you can say
this building isn't a found in a
foundation most of us just buy our homes
and we own them and that not anymore
sell our houses we can't buy a house we
can't rent anywhere but I think Jeremy
will find that he's protected from all
that fancy the money
he doesn't even pay inheritance taxes
when you saw the outpouring of grief
when you saw the British public do what
they did right yeah does that not make
you think that the British public
support the monarchy serious question
they supported the queen certainly
unquestionably because the funeral they
could uh no it didn't I caught the end
of it in St George's uh I thought the
queue was impressive and people wanted
to pay them
and I'm a respect
when he arrived at Buckingham Palace
first time there was Applause for him
there was cheers for him he went in on a
walkabout a woman pulled him forward to
give him a kiss on the cheek no
Protection Officer pulled her away the
people enjoyed it he stopped his car the
following day in the mouth didn't
Improvement the people who went to the
ground running the people the people
they were his supporters it's like same
oh no
you can't say that all it will be
praised the initial signs aren't that
the public support King Charles because
they just do and he's played a Blinder
ever since he took over
evolving the people as you said she's
very interesting any Monarch nowadays I
I suspect you're right the
accountability in the scrutiny is far
greater than the queen I don't think
anybody will ever Follow The Queen I
think it's it's like trying to follow
this is a ridiculous analogy forgive me
for Alex Ferguson at Manchester United
it's just not possible was it I think
the queen transcended everything and
give Charles a chance I think that's
what we're saying I agree fantastic
thank you